كما العاده يكون معنا هنا المحلل العسكري
والخبير الاستراتيجي اللواء فايز الدويري
وقبل ان نبدا بالتحليل معك لواء فايز نبدا
بقراءه لهذه الاحداث على الخارطه
التفاعليه معك عبد القادر عرب نعم اياده
ويمكن ان اختصرها في ان المقاومه تصعد
بالاساس شمالا وحينما نشير الى الشمال
فنحن بضروره ننتقل الى المناطق التي
اعتدنا على الحديث عنها بالخصوص هذه
المناطق الشماليه لمدينه غزه الاخبار
المتلاحقه تحدثت عن استهداف المقاومه
وتحديدا كتائب القسام لاعلانها عن
استهدافي
لثمان دبابات اسرائيليه منع ميركافا على
محور التفاح والدرج وحينما نذكر التفاح
والدرج فنحن نشير الى هذا المحور الذي
اعلنت القسام امس عن استهدافها لنقله جند
واعلنت عن قتلها لعشره جنود من المسافه
الصفر على هذا المحور اذا كما نلاحظ هذا
محور متفاعل ومحور ساخن كما ياتي ايضا
بينما كنا
كجزيرة
شهدت تطورات ونحن نشير بالضروره الى منطقه
الشيخ رضوان ومنطقه الشيخ رضوان في شمال
غرب مدينه غزه حيث اعلنت ايضا القسام عن
استهدافات وعن اشتباكات هنا مع قوه
اسرائيليه متوغل وقالت بانها اردت بين 20
جنديا بين قتيل وجريح على مستوى هذه الجبه
اذا نلاحظ بان اضافه الى هذه المحاور هناك
ايضا التهاب في هذه الجبهه جبهه الشيخ
رضوان اللافت الاخر على الجبهه الشماليه
دوما هي هذه التطورات وحينما نشير لها نحن
بالضروره ننتقل الى تطورات متلاحقه هنا في
منطقه الشيخ عجلين واللافت هو ما اعلنته
القسام ايضا عن استهداف عدد من الجنود
الاسرائيليين هنا بقوه متحصنه داخل احد
المنازل في الشيخ عجلين لكن اعل ت ايضا عن
عمليه قنس لاحد الجنود الاسرائيليين وذلك
ببندقيه من نوع ام
99 من الشيخ عجلين الى الشيخ رضوان وصولا
الى المنطقه ايضا الشماليه التي اشرنا
اليها كان هناك قصف اسرائيلي مكثف لمناطق
الشمال وتحديدا قصف على جباليه ونذكر بما
اعلنته القسام امس ايضا عن تمكنها من
الاستحواذ على طائره مسيره هنا في غرب بيت
حنون لو انتقلنا الى المنطقه الوسطى وبها
ايضا تطورات لافته نذكر بان القوات
الاسرائيليه كتفت من عمليه القصف على
المنطقه الوسطى وتحديدا منطقه البريج
واستهداف البريج ياتي بينما ايضا اعلنت
القسام عن تمكنها من استهداف خمس او ست
دبابات اسرائيليه ونقلي جند على مستوى هذا
المحور نذكر بان البريج وهو احد المخيمات
التي التي اعلنت القوات الاسرائيليه على
الهجومي عليه ياتي بينما ايضا كان هناك
استهداف لمخيمات النصيرات ومنطقه الزوايده
ولكن ايضا مخيم المغازي واللافت هو ايضا
عمليه القصف التي طالت حتى منطقه دير
البرح وذلك انطلاقا من البحر حتى خان يونس
تم قصفها من زوارق حربيه اسرائيليه من
البحر لو انتقلنا الى المنطقه الاخيره وهي
المنطقه الجنوبيه واللافت هو ايضا ظاهره
استهداف قوى متحصنه داخل المنازل القسام
اعلنت عن استهدافي ايضا قوه متحصنه هنا في
وسط مدينه خان يونس خان يونس التي تقدمت
فيها القوات الاسرائيليه على اكبر من محور
القسام تعلن عن تمكنها من استهداف هذه
القوه هناك اشتباكات على اكثر من محور
خصوصا في مناطق بني سهيله ولكن ايضا في
مناطق خزاعه اذا تطورات على اكثر من صعيد
لعل اللافته فيها القط صحيح شكرا جزيلا لك
عبد القادر ولكن سنعود الى الشمال تحديدا
الشيخ عجلين تطورات لافته هناك في الساعات
الاخيره لنتحدث عن نو عمليات نوعيه في
الشيخ عجلين استخدام بندقيه سلاح جديد
يدخل على خط الاسلحه المستخدمه من قبل
المقاومه ام 99 تي بي جي بدا معروفا ان
المقاومه تستخدمه ولكن استخدمت ايضا في
الشيخ عجلين ضد قوى راجله بالاضافه الى
استهداف قوه في سياره هامر تحديدا نبدا
بسلاح الام 99
الان دعنا في جمله واحده عن الشيخ عجلين
هذه دخلتها القوات الجيش الاحتلال في
الاسبوع الاول من المعركه البريه بعد ان
وصلوا الى
اي شارع
الرشيد انعطف للجهه الشماليه وبدات بدانا
نتحدث في تلك الفتره عن الشيخ عجلين ثم لم
يعد هناك احداث لكن ها هو اليوم بعد
تقريبا 60 يوم من بدء المعركه البريه نجد
انه الشيخ عجلين عاد الى الواجهه بثلاث اي
عمليات نوعيه اولا بندقيه القنص وهي ام 99
هي بندقيه صينيه
مداها المدى الفاعل
1540 متر
وتستطيع التسديد لغايه 1600 متر بسرعه
بسرعه ضعف الصوت
اي
12.7 يمكن ان تخترق الاليات ودرجه اصابها
ت عاليه جدا طولها متر ونص وزنها تقريبا
تريب 12 كيلوغرام فهي تضاف الى البندقيه
التصنيع المحلي اللي هي بندقيه ال ا هذه
هي البندقيه وهي تعتبر اضافه نوعيه اذا
على اس نعم نعم كسلاح فردي هذه المخزن
يتسع على خمس طلقات يعني مخزنها خمس طلقات
لانه لانه لا تستخدم رمايه اوتوماتيكيه هي
عمليه قنس وبالتالي الرامي الماهر خمس
طلقات بخمس اشخاص هذه يجب ان تكون النتيجه
حتميه الامر الثاني استخدموا التي بيجي ضد
احد المباني المحسن وهي تعتب عمليه نوعيه
تبنى على استطلاع وكذلك عمليه المراقبه
والاستطلاع الدائم افضت الى مهاجمه
باستخدام سواء تاندم او الياسين عربتي همر
وهذه عاده لا تتحرك بدون ان تكون تحمل
الافراد والافراد قد يكون من سته الى
ثانيه حسب الظرف الميداني وطبيعه المهمه
التي هذه اذا دعينا نقول الشيخ عجلين بعد
غياب استمر لاسابيع تقريبا ما يقارب سبعه
اسابيع تعود وتتصدر المشهد من جديد بثلاث
عمليات نوعيه اذا ذهبنا للمناطق الاخرى
المناطق منطقه الشيخ رضوان الشيخ رضوان
هنا يبدو الارتباك في في طريقه اداره
المعركه الشيخ رضوان الجزء الشرقي منه تم
الانسحاب قبل اربعه ايام تقريبا وكانت
تاتي بعد الحديث عن الانكفاء او محاوله
ايجاد منطقه عازله لكن بقي جزء من القوه
في الجزء الغربي هذه كذلك تم الوصول لها
في بدايه او منتصف الاسبوع الثاني عندما
دخلوا من التوام باتجاه دوار الامن العام
اتجهوا جنوبا مع شارع النصر واصبح بتماس
مع الشيخ رضوان ودخلوا الى عمق حوالي 800
متر من الشيخ رضوان هم انسحبوا قبل عده
ايام اربعه ايام والان بقيت بقيه القوه
لكن لا افا جا ان نسمع بعد ما جرى في هذا
اليوم 20 قتيل
و نسمع في الساعات او الايام القادمه
اخلاء منطقه الشيخ رضوان نذهب الى المنطقه
الاكثر
احتداماً هكذا اقرا المعركه لكن بالمجمل
مناطق الشمال لا تزال مشتعله بشكل كبيرم
لا يزال لا يزال القتال في اعنف مراحله
حتى في بيت حنون نعم نعم بالامس اسقط
الطائره ويتم بيت حنون تم تسويتها بالارض
لم يعد فيها هناك اي مبنى رغم ذلك لا يزال
يستهدفها بالطائرات لانه هناك مقاتلين لا
يزالوا يصلوا ويخرجوا من شبكات الانفاق
وهذا ما يدحض كلام ه جاري الان هذه
المنطقه تم تاشيره هذه تمث يعني صوره
مصغره عنما يجري في الجنوب لانه في الجنوب
القتال اكثر هنا لماذا اقول هذا الكلام هي
معارك حاده
وتدفع قوات جيش الاحتلال ضرائب ضرائب
ضريبه حقيقيه لكن اقول لان حجم القوه اللي
هنا اقل من حجم القوات اللي في الج لانه
تم سحب جزء من هذه المنطقه من القوات
وارسالها الى المنطقه الوسطى والجنوبيه
لتعزيزها فاذا انتقلنا جنوبا ال منطقه
الوسط حي
البريج منطقه المخيمات و بعد وادي غزه
الان لو في جمله واحده اي جحر الديك لا
يزال يذكرنا ا لا يزال يذكرنا وبالتالي
غزه كلها جهر الديك غزه بالكامل الان
منطقه البريج بعد الفشل في اليوم الاول من
اجل ال التقدم وفصل المخيمات عن بعضها
البعض لجا اي الى العوده تي الى الوراء
اعاد تنظيم قواته وبدا مهاجمه البريج
بصوره رئيسيه من الجهه الشماليه ومن الجهه
الشرقيه مع قصف ناري من المنطقه الجنوبيه
مع مع حركات خفيفه لكن في هذا رغم الضريبه
الباهضه التي دفعها حاول صباح هذا اليوم
ان يقوم بهجوم جديد ولكنه فشل وتراجعت
القوات من منطقه حدود البريج الى منطقه ال
الحاجز المغازي يتعرض الى قصف الصيرات
يتعرض الى قصف لكن لا توجد عمليات بريه
حقيقيه نذهب الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
ص خان يونس تحديدا قال وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي هنا انه هناك تركيز في
العمليات في هذه المرحله على خان يونس سبق
وقلنا قبل ان يتحدث انه ما ك كانت في اوج
معركه الشجاعيه وعندما تم سحب الكتيبه 13
اللواء جولاني بعد ان خسرت 40% وليس 41
جندي قلنا بان بان معرك حركه الشجاعيه هي
عباره عن صوره مصغره عن ما سيجري في منطقه
خان يونس بسبب اختلاف المعطيات هذه منطقه
واسعه المباني فيها ليست بكثافه المباني
هي منطقه كما توصف بالمنطقه التي تصلح
لحركه
الاليات المدرعه دفع بخمسه الويه كانت
اندفاع الاولى مبنيه على خطه احاطه من
الشمال والجنوب فاتجه من القرا
الى شارع صلاح الدين انحرف جنوبا باتجاه
المطاح ثم غربا باتجاه المطاحن ووصل الى
منطقه ابراج الحمد لو تنزل الخارطه شوي لو
سمحت وصل الى
منطقه الى الى اطراف مدينه الحمد وصل الى
منطقه المواصي اجرى عمليه انزال قبل قبل
عده اسابيع من اجل
ايصال المواد طيب سق قاطعك لحظات لواء
فايز لينوه بهذا الخبر العاجل الان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلن ان هناك
431 عسكريا جريح ما يزالون يتلقون العلاج
في المستشفيات بينهم 44 في حاله صعبه او
خطيره هذه تقديرات الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي
بات التقديرات الجزئيه يطر يوميا لحديث عن
ارقام جديده اريد ان اتوقف عند خانيونس
تحديدا الالويه اصبحت سبعه سبعه ساتي على
ذكري اذا سمحتي لانه دعيني اوصف فقط
المعركه هو في البدايه بدا من كسفين
باتجاه القراره وصل لشارع صلاح الدين
انعطف جنوبا باتجاه المطاحن وحاول ان يعمل
حركه التفاف بحيث يصل الى شارع الرشيد من
خلال مدينه حمد ويصل الى المواصي والى جوش
قطيف وحاول في نفس الفتره اذا عدنا الى
الاحداث ان ان يتحرك من المنطقه الجنوبيه
يتجنب بن سهيلا وعبس الكبيره من منطقه
الفخاري لحله يعمل احاطه مزد وجه كما فعل
في منطقه مدينه غزه لانه كان الهجوم على
شكل فكي كماشه هنا اخفق القوات التي تم
الدفع بها في منطقه بني سهيله منطقه عبسان
الجديده عبسان الكبيره وزنه وخزاعه لم
تستطع ان تحقق بعد مرور اسابيع ولم تستطع
الوصول الى شارع صلاح الدين شارع صلاح
الدين للمعل للعلم هو الشارع لو تاشر لنا
يا بالله شارع صلاح الدين هو الحد الفاصل
بين مدينه خان يونس وبني سيلا بمعنى اخر
لم يصل خان يونس بعد يعني انا لا اتحدث
الان عن معارك خان يونس المنطقه الشرقيه
لم يستطع الوصول الى خان يونس الان عندما
فشل في تحقيق الوصول والاختراق
هو حصل على التماس من المنطقه الشماليه
والشماليه الغربيه لا انكر ذلك القوات
التي ذهبت باتجاه المواصي وباتجاه جوش
قطيف هي نعم في قتال مع الاطراف الشماليه
لكن من المنطقه الشرقيه لم لم يستطع ماذا
ماذا فعل دفع في اللواء السادس قبل 48
ساعه اللواء رقم سته اللواء رقم سته او
اللواء السادس لم يحقق الانجاز كانت
الخطوه البديله له ان يبحث عن شكل مناوره
جديد شكل المناوره دفع بالفرقه 36 الى
منطقه البريج من اجل لانه هو يعرف ان
الدفاع جغرافي ا لواء غزه لواء خان يونس
موجود يعتبر من اقوى الالويه لماذا لانه
المساحه التي يدافع عنها واسعه جدا كذلك
يوجد يوجد في هذه المنطقه نخبه القوات من
الفصائل الاخرى خاصه الجهاد الاسلامي الان
من اجل
ان يضعف القدره القتاليه من خلال اجبار
المقاتلين على سحب جزء من هذه القوات
لمواجهه الخطر القادم في منطقه البريج
هكذا كان يعتقد فدفعت الفرقه 36 المدرعه
الفرقه 36 مدرعه لم تحقق واجبها وغاصت في
رمال البريج ماذا كان في تلك الفتره
تزامنت في جمله واحده تزامنت في تلك
الفتره الخسائر اصبحت باهظه جدا في هذه
المنطقه ومعظمها في الاليات لماذا لانه
كان هناك سوء اداره معركه ان معظم الاليات
الالويه التي دفعت كانت اما قوات محموله
او ميكانيكيه محموله او قوات دبابات فدفع
باللواء السابع وهو من قوات المظليين من
اجل ان يؤمن الحمايه ل للمعدات القتال انه
تعتبر شبه عمياء رغم
ال
بص معطف الريح الذي ي الذي يستخدم لحمايه
الدبابه فالان اصبح هنا سبعه الويه ثلا
الويه في الوسط وهناك تقريبا نوعيه
الالويه لواء فايز التي يتم الدفع بها
خاصه في خانيونس عندما نستخدم سلاح
المظليين هل يفيد في المعركه قوات
المظليين يعني
هو عندهم الان قوات المظليين لا يعني ذلك
بانهم سيقوموا بتوظيفهم من خلال الانزال
بالمظلات هم الان يقومون بعمليه التمشيط
نعم السبب هي ليست عمليه تمشيط هي عمليه
تمشيط جز هذا كلام هي عمليه تامين حمايه
للاليات المتقدمه من خلالها تتم عمليه
التمشيط اذا هو الاصل حمايه الاليات التي
اصبحت هدفا وصيدا سهلا لكن لماذا
المظليين الدورات
التدريبيه لهذه القوات تجعلها من قوات
النخبه المقاتل لديه لياقه مدنيه عاليه
مهاره في استخدام السلاح لديه تدريب عنيف
جدا وبالتالي قد هي تكافئ ولكن تتميز في
نقاط اضافيه اللي هي النزول بالمظلات
جفعاتي وجولان طيب لنذهب الى رفح الان
بدانا نشاهد فيديوهات تنشر من المقاومه في
رفح تحديدا هذا الفيديو من هناك ويظهر
استخدام قذائف الهاون تحديدا في استهداف
قوات العدو كيف تقرا هذه الصور الان من
رفح رفح هي جزء من المعركه وكان هناك قبل
عده ايام محاوله
اي محور فيلادلفيا وتحدثنا عنه في بعض
المقابلات لانه كانت الخطه عندما بدا
الحديث عن انشاء منطقه عازله انا كان
تصوري للمنطقه العازله وقد نكون وفقنا
بانه يسعى للسيطره على المناطق الزراعيه
اولا لحما لحرمان اهل غزه من اي مصدر اخر
لانه يجب ان يكون من خلال اي كمريض
الانعاش من خلال الدرب الاسرائيلي وهذا
غير وارد وتحدثت عن السيطره على المناطق
الزراعيه من الاتجاهات الثلاث الشماليه
والشرقيه والجنوبيه رغم خصوص خصوصيه
المنطقه الجنوبيه توجد جمهوريه مصر
العربيه وسيسعى للسيطره على شريط في وادي
غزه من منطقه جحر الديك حتى الرشيد اقل
شيء بعرض 1 كم هكذا كانت القراءه وجاءت ال
المعلومات من داخل الكيان ب بانها يعني
اثبتت اي قراءتنا الاستشراف لطبيعه
المعركه فهذه المنطقه رفح تتعرض لعمليات
قصف ممنهج وهي مصنفه على انها المنطقه
الامنه والملاذ الامن لكن بعض المسؤولين
الامريكيين ماذا قال قال ليفتح معبر رفح
وليخرج الغزيين الى السعوديه والى الاردن
والى تركيا هكذا تدار السياسه القذره طيب
لننتقل الى فيديو بثته قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من خانيونس وقالت انه استهداف
لمبنى الاستخبارات العسكريه التابعه لحركه
حماس تحديدا بالبدايه نريد ان نشير الى
جزئيه ان قوات الاحتلال بدات تكثف
الفيديوهات التي تقوم بنشرها والله انا
اكون سعيد جدا لو تم عرض عشر فيديوهات
يومي لانه لا اجد العناء في في التحليل
ولا يعني في عندما اشاهد فيلدي ل الفصال
الفلسطينيه في بعض الحالات بعد ان احلله
المره الاولى اعود واشاهد مره ومرتين على
السرعه البطيئه لانه في اللحظه الاولى لا
استطيع ان ا بكافه التفاصيل فبالتالي قد
يكون تحليلي في المره الثانيه اوسع واشمل
من المره الاولى لكن هنا انا اعتبر هذه
فرصه الي انا كمحلل اني ارتاح لانه
القراءه واحده من الفيديو الاول عندما
وضع عندما وضعت الدائره على شباك المدرسه
حتى هذه اللحظه نفس الفيديو هو الان يطلق
النار على عدو مجهول لا ارى شيء شاهدنا
حاله واحده فقط وقد يكون ندم جيش الاحتلال
عل
عندما اصيب احد المقاتلين من طائره من
طائره الرون وانهى حياته ساجدا بين يدي
الله شكرا جزيلا لك لواء فايز الدويري نصل
بذلك الى ختام هذه النافذه التحليليه
مشاهدينا نعود بكم الان الى غرفه الاخبار
وزميل سفيان شكرا جزيلا لك مياده